the government has tipped it's racist
Windrush rehand
yet again with the deportation of
Jamaican nationals they say they're
removing violent criminals from this
country to keep the public safe but what
about rashon Davis one of those who was
due to be on the flight earlier this
week he was sentenced to 14 months in
jail but only served to because in 2016
our system decided that you can't
convict someone for simply being present
when someone else commits robbery this
father of two who came to the UK aged 11
and knows nobody in Jamaica has
committed no crime since his release
people will tell you that the government
is just trying to keep us safe
but if even one of them clearly poses a
no risk to society then that's not the
reason they're doing it let's be clear
in something the at least 83 citizens
who were deported in the Windrush
scandal were British citizens so when
our Conservative government got rid of
people whose only distinguishing factor
from the rest of the population was
their ethnic origin it was racist you
know for me I think it's outrageous that
that you in the same breath you
mentioned Windrush you say the races the
wind rushing hand these two things are
entirely different Windrush was a
scandal it was shameful it was a group
of Commonwealth citizens many of whom
had lived in this country for decades
who were chucked out because apparently
they didn't have the proper paperwork so
it was deemed that they were illegally
and they were thrown out shameful that
is our government shame this isn't
highly different this is a group of
hardened criminals all the first the
original 56 300 years prison sentence
between them they were in that crowd
there were killers there were rapists
there were drug dealers there were sex
offenders that's in the original 56 and
you dare to compare that to Windrush
it's not it's nothing like the same and
that we the the people of this country
one of the people who was taken out of
that 56 was a killer he was a man he was
a Jamaican drug dealer he actually
it's hard to even say he took a claw
hammer and he took a kitchen knife and
he killed a young mother in front of her
six-year-old daughter and then when the
door to try to intervene she was
battered - you're saying that these
people have rights in these countries
you also said a lot of them were that
most of them were British citizens they
were not there were foreign nationals
there's a different a lot of them were
given leave to remain in this country
and and if you if you get given the
privilege of staying in this country and
you abuse that privilege by killing
people by raping people by selling drugs
to kids you shouldn't be allowed to stay
here so as I just said I anticipated you
would try and point to the worst of the
worst I told you a specific story and a
lot of a fart of a father of two father
of two who apparently was it was wrongly
convicted because they changed the law
in 2016 to find that his original
conviction was wrong he served two
months in prison what about the Romans
in the race and the sex of it here's my
point if even one of them within that
group no was it public spas to zero risk
to society yes you can we can make a
separate argument for the rapist the
killers etc but for this particular one
if they're including people who oppose
no risk to society there's no even risk
reason to get rid of them how Bennett
you say pose no risk all of those people
had served at least one year in prison
he had he hadn't he served two months
that's my point
he served two months he was wrongly
convicted or you've also got Twain
Morgan who served two tours in
Afghanistan fighting for this country
piracy and suffered PTSD for which he
got no help and ended up committing GBH
that is a failure of our country now
Jimmy one of our veteran this is a
killer than the rapist I was involved
via LBC show and speaking out frequently
about the deportation of crack Elida
Bonnie who was a convicted for financial
fraud but had been in this country since
he was a child and I think I think there
is I think there is a room here to
recognize your point that this isn't
Windrush when rush were not criminally
convicted but also I think to
acknowledge that there is a broader
question a question mark around
citizenship that has emerged poster Isis
blinds debate and it's not fully
transparent nor clear nor consistence at
everybody where they should apply and
where they shouldn't hence the ruling
actually because of judicial review
so stop half of these deportations and
then downing streets criticism of that
ruling and I think actually pretty much
we could all probably agree that there
is room for some deportations if you
arrived in this country yesterday and
murder say ten people then you're gonna
go back to five to five years ago and
you murdered so I'm saying that that's
one end of it and the other end of
course is if somebody came here at two
years old and then let's have a look
there's an example of it actually
so Michael McDonald and he's in
detention awaiting deportation to
Jamaica he said when the government
talks about sending me back they mean a
place that's back in quotation marks
they mean a place that's completely
foreign to me Jamaica I have no family
in Jamaica
my parents siblings aunts and uncles all
live in the UK and a British citizenship
I first came here 20 years ago when I
was nine but it is where I went to
school and raised the family a prison
sentence has already ripped mine apart I
don't want to think about what will
happen to my family if I'm sent to
Jamaica there is surely room for
conversation about even perhaps he was
nine someone came here at three or four
but he don't commit serious crimes yeah
well I think that that's right you know
one of the things about these
deportations and the numbers involved is
precisely that we don't know we don't
know some of them maybe Windrush and
some of them may know the ones that were
the ones that were deported but there
were there was a number we've got this
or not we have a let me finish no but we
have to do this anyway - were people
convicted of rape three were convicted
of violent crime eight convicted of drug
offenses three convicted of robbery of
firearm offences one of them new age was
talking about the ones that weren't
deport exactly I was talking about the
ones that weren't deported and the point
about this is look after Windrush which
we all agree was horrendous despicable
shameful the government had a review
lessons learned review and one of the
recommendations until that review had
concluded and published its reports now
as it happened as it happens bits of
that report have already been leaked and
it is damning it is absolutely damning
it is accusing the government were
failing to ensure to adhere to its legal
duty to ensure equality and one of the
things that recommends is that people
who arrived in the UK as children up to
the age of 13 should not be deported now
my question is why hasn't the government
just waited until it published that
review before moving things forward what
is the reason for that let me tell you
what the Home Office is saying foreign
nationals who abuse our hospitality by
committing crimes in the UK should be in
no doubt of our determination to deport
them since 2010 we have carried out
enforced returns to 193 different
countries we make no apology whatsoever
for seeking to remove dangerous foreign
criminals they added in the year ending
September 2019 there were 49 and forced
returns as they're called to Jamaica in
the same period we returned more
individuals to 26 other countries
including Romania Albania Poland Brazil
Ukraine and Pakistan so that's what the
home office say um I think it's clumsy
and unfair to use Windrush I really do
nobody in the wind rush course it
committed any crime these are some of
them it's quite low-level crime some of
it we are talking rape women and rape
and killing what you had are you aware
of what the deportation process is and
the number of hurdles that has to be
cleared so upon conviction the person
has given 10 years and they are with a
recommendation to be deported so that's
hurdle 1 they serve 5 then a notice of
intent to deport is served on them they
get legal advice then those who then get
another legal but in some instances I
don't know about these cases they've
certainly got to satisfy two judges and
a panel in some instances they satisfy
three four judges and a panel before
they are deported we don't know the ins
and outs of all the cases I am prepared
because of my faith in British justice
if they've done enough to persuade
possibly certainly two judges possibly
three and the panel these people need a
concrete example of somebody whose
conviction was overturned precisely
because that a judge would have ruled
that he or she here the judge would have
ruled that he has to go someone who was
present at the time that two mobile
phones were stolen who in 2016 the court
decided that this was not done as you
deliberate nor am i quote a judge will
have had to be satisfied and it's undone
so clearly wrongly couldn't anybody
honestly you're better than the Janice
can anybody honestly say that a father
of two who was wrong who was wrongly
sent wrongly sentenced needs to be
kicked out of the country I mean I was
talking about before who I can't name
there are various things in process have
they deported them when they should have
the person who he killed would still be
alive today
and either the family of that girl and
all the other people who've been
murdered not what killed manslaughter
raped people listening to you thinking
and and and use to an extent racial and
thinking that you put the human rights
of these criminals above the human
rights of decent law-abiding British
citizens and that's what it sounds like
it's it's about treating people with
dignity and applying the law humane and
you say we don't trust the legal system
the problem is that we don't trust the
government